it's colder than Antarctica in Chicago
this major American city all but
deserted except for a few brave souls
it's so cold that your eyelashes are
frozen what's it like being outside at
least my dear
lordy Lordy it is cold my teeth are
called my lips are frozen and I've only
been out here about two minutes you're
shivering yes I am I'm from Atlanta
Georgia we don't get this cold with the
windchill
these are dangerous conditions the
city's homeless population their main
concern no one you know in need of a
safer warm place to stay
we'll be turned away no one our
number-one priority is the safety and
security of our residents especially the
most vulnerable and it's not just
Chicago that's suffering this weather
event is called a polar vortex which is
when very cold air rushes south from the
Arctic this one is particularly dramatic
and widespread which means that tens of
millions of people across this country
are facing this plunge in temperatures
in many places it's not safe to keep
schools and businesses open thousands of
flights have been canceled
and travel is treacherous on frozen
roads for those drivers who've ignored
advice to stay put and although the US
Postal Service has tried its best it's
been too much mail delivery suspended in
some regions this was looking to be like
the really great winter December was
really warm but I knew we were gonna pay
for it and yeah we're really paying for
it now yeah this is just really cold in
a few days it is due to warm up but for
now there is little to do but stay
inside and wait for this record-breaking
deep freeze to end